in this video i want to talk about why
you're probably not closing as many
sales as you hope you are now there's a
lot of opponents components to closing
deals right you have the actual offer
itself price point the prospect the
process they went through so i actually
think there's five p's in in that have
to happen and be in alignment prior to
the sale so the first is the promotion
for the right prospect at the right
price for the right product following
the right process right those are the
five fees that i think through when i'm
looking at an entire sales pipeline but
what i want to talk about specifically
today is why even if you're following
those things correctly and you're
getting on the phone you have a script
that you know works or your team has a
script that you you wrote out because
you know it works right if they're not
closing then it means that they may be
saying the right things but they may be
saying it the wrong way and so there's
two components to saying
the right things the right way all right
so one is tone and the second
is um is cadence right it's emphasis and
so i want to give you an example of both
of those things so for example if i were
to um give you a script like you know
jerry seinfeld's uh comedy script and
you were to get on stage and you were
trying to deliver that right the tone
the pauses that you would have would not
be the same as his right his intonations
would be different than yours are and so
as a result he would be funny and you
would not be and you'd be wondering like
will this work for jerry why is it not
working for me and so just like that you
may be looking at your team and
wondering like well this works for me
why is it not working for them and
you're looking and they're saying the
words but you're like why is this not
working it's because they're saying them
the wrong way and so let me illustrate
this in a different way so if i were to
say my own name so if layla my wife
calls me and she says alex right or alex
or alex
right all three of those are just my
name right said differently have
different meanings i'll give you another
example i got this from jason flatland i
love this i didn't say he hit his wife i
didn't say he hit his wife i didn't say
he hit his wife i didn't say he hit his
wife i didn't say he hit his wife i
didn't say he hit his wife i didn't say
he hit his wife
right and so each of those sentences has
different meaning right because of the
emphasis that we put on the words and so
just like both so one is you have the
tone that you're using the pauses
where you put
emphasis right and then you have how
you're saying the words and so what
happens is you have somebody who's
reading a script but they aren't reading
it the right way there's two ways to fix
this right one of them is to become a
master salesman right and learn how to
control your tone right learn when to
lower your voice so that what you're
saying shows the prospect that it's
really important right so i'm slowing
down what i'm saying i'm lowering my
tone so that you know that you need to
pay attention to what i'm saying whereas
if i'm really excited i'm talking about
all this stuff that's really exciting
and we're like we're all we're all
fast-paced we're all up here right then
that's gonna it's gonna communicate
something different even if we're both
saying the same words and so one of
those things happens from repetition
right you learn you start to learn this
stuff because you're like man i nailed
that sale what did i do right and so one
of my side note recommendations for
everyone is everyone here hopefully has
been on a hot trick at some point like
there's some days you get on the phone
you're like man i can just close anyone
right now when you are hot
those are the videos you should watch
that's the game take footage that you
should go over and over and over again
like in the beginning you might not have
that you have to watch other people's
stuff but when you're hot
you say things differently you pause at
different points and it's those micro
nuances that create master salesman and
the true master salesman right the
difference between a 250 batter and a
300 batter right for a baseball analogy
it's like one one hit every two or three
games right it's not a huge difference
but that's the difference between a
master salesman and a porsche an average
salesman is that great salesmen never
get cold they are always on a hot streak
because they know how to recreate
success and it's because they know how
to say the things the right way for the
right prospect and so
to wrap this up for you if you have your
sales team right the easiest tactic is
to get them to a watch the footage of
themselves when they were hot and if
they haven't watch other people who were
hot
and what they were saying at that point
because there were minor ways and
tonality and shifts and pauses that you
will do when you are assuming the close
the right way when you're projecting the
confidence when you have the conviction
that communicates differently let me
give you a fun tip that i found like we
always close the highest percentage on
our on our deals when we had people
finishing our program right because on
the days that we would finish our
cohorts our groups of clients
we'd have all these success stories that
would go again after another after
another after another we did all these
interviews on one day and so my sales
team would watch this happen and then
they would get on the phones and they
would be so convicted about what they
were selling and so this leads into the
two ways that you can fix this right so
number one is you become a master
salesman you become a master salesman
through repetition and through studying
gamete footage which is the first thing
i said the second way and the faster way
of doing this is to believe in what you
sell this is hard i'll be real with you
right this is this is hard for a lot of
people especially if you're a business
owner because you know all the problems
in your business there are always going
to be problems and those aren't going to
go away and so one of the things that i
have i have hacked in my own mind is is
asking two other questions which is i
will never have a perfect product and
i'll tell you that right now but i can
have perfect intentions right and so
that is something that you can delineate
for yourself number one and you know
your intentions so if your intentions
aren't perfect then you can fix those
and you can have perfect intentions
right but your product will never be
because can always improve right
the second thing in terms of improving
it is knowing that the prospect will be
better served
working with you than with anyone else
and so that is something that i have i
have looked at and so this is easier for
somebody who's getting into a
marketplace and you can see the other
competitors that are there you may not
be perfect but you can believe that
you're the absolute best shot that this
person has to be successful and this is
especially true if you have some sort of
education or training type business
where someone is required to do
something so like if you were if you're
helping someone with life coaching
you're helping someone with weight loss
you're helping someone with with their
business like these are all skills that
they have to develop you cannot eat the
food for someone you cannot do the
push-ups for someone you cannot hop on
the sales call for them they have to
learn the skill which means that you can
provide something but they also have to
come the other half the half the
distance right and so the way to
continue to have that conviction is one
recognize your intentions if you can fix
your intentions to know that your
intentions are perfect then that is
going to be a huge step forward that
you'll have over your competition
because then it will force you it will
cause you to say the things the right
way because people can feel conviction
they can feel the subtle nuances of how
you communicate and they will choose to
believe you not based on what you say
but on how you say it and the second way
is by making sure that your product is
the best and that it is the best shot
that this person has you can't say i
guarantee that you're going to lose
weight i can't say i'll guarantee that
you're going to make more money because
you can't because you can't control the
variables but you can guarantee that you
will be the best shot that this person
has at being successful and so for me
cracking that code uh mentally helped me
a lot especially in in weight loss sales
when i was starting out right because i
would have someone in and i knew the
stats i knew that in six months you know
half the people who were signing up
weren't going to be at the gym i knew
that right but the thing is is i can't
look at someone and say like well you
know what maybe maybe they shouldn't
sign up because i mean half the people
aren't gonna aren't gonna show up you
know within six months but instead i was
able to shift and this was something i
had to learn that i'm still the best
shot this person has at getting where
they want to go right they're still
going to have to do stuff on their part
but i know with conviction that my
intentions are perfect and that i am the
best shot they have at getting where
they want to go and that is the
conviction that i can stand on that i
can look someone in the eyes through
their soul and tell them that i were the
best shot for them to be successful and
that is how you can change the way you
speak so you can speak with conviction
to a prospect and that is what i found
and so hopefully you find this valuable
if you are not selling or your team is
not selling the way you want it it's not
necessarily because the words you are
saying sure it's all the other things
that i said the promotion the offer that
you're running right the the process
that you're taking them through the
price that you're selling it uh who you
are selling to the prospect themselves
all of those things are gonna be things
that are gonna weigh into whether or not
it's successful but once you are
actually on the phone with the person
fundamentally a sale is simply a
transfer of belief and if you do not
believe then you cannot transfer that
belief and the way that you communicate
belief is not in what you say but how
you say it and so hopefully that was
valuable for you if you like this stuff
click subscribe my name is alex ramose i
have a portfolio of companies that does
85 million a year in revenue and i have
absolutely nothing to sell you i hope
you found value this click subscribe
i'll see in the next vid bye